yeah oh my god guys that's the secret
that ali has just revealed to you guys
get the laundry detergent out
islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in norway
every person who prays there every kid
that learns about islam every youngster
that memorize the quran all of this and
so much more can be on your scale of
good deeds click the link and donate
what you can
assalamu alaikum what happened today
better care to brothers and sisters in
the affairs how you guys are well
inshallah so as you guys know i have
done two videos with ollie honey how are
you doing i'm really good thank you so
nice to be here it's a little bit cold
but it's very sunny it is yes um so as
you guys you guys have surprised
probably oh my gosh what's ali we're
doing with ollie now you guys remember
i've done a reaction video for about
olly and his plastic surgery that he'd
done etc and then i came across him in
uh leicester square it was a surprise
wasn't it it was it was a bit
interesting because i was watching
because he was doing a little um music
christmas and career video exactly so
obviously we could spot you from your
outfit i did look very dramatic that day
yeah yeah okay
yeah so when i saw you i was like i
looked at my friend i was like
yeah it is he was busy we didn't want to
like interrupt et cetera but i think he
came to you and he said to you know do
you like to have a discussion etc he was
busy that day we had a little discussion
we talked about islam uh but then oli
got in contact with me through instagram
and he said look um i would like to know
more about islam and obviously we don't
want to make this video just about that
i would like to know more about you as
well you know so yeah so firstly um how
did you come across the video
so i when i met you um you know
obviously you filmed it and stuff so
then i checked out your channel and then
when it was uh when it came up i got
like a notification so i watched and i
thought you know this was really great
but i just felt bad because i didn't
have much time that day i was filming
and we only chatted for like you know 10
minutes so i thought you know let's have
a more in-depth discussion i found it
very interesting what you're saying i
love learning about uh the world i'd
love to learn more about islam and stuff
and also to learn more about you because
i know you do so many different youtubes
on you do your halal food reviews you do
um which we're gonna we're gonna have
it's called dining to jannah jenna means
paradise okay so in the hereafter okay
so dining we're dying in two paradises
okay that's what the theme is but we
might have ollie come in there we might
maybe go to korea if it's korean korean
halal guys i'm up for that
we're gonna be gonna find a korean place
uh inshallah and he's gonna take us and
we'll probably review food together yeah
we both love eating yeah i haven't tried
korean food before you've never tried it
i've never tried it oh my god you're
missing out i i certainly am you know
definitely so um
yeah so when it comes to like is there a
specific question you would like to ask
oh um i just want to learn more so
obviously last time we were reading some
passages from the quran you were telling
me about islam and you know i know i
studied history so i know a lot about um
the history of islam and stuff which i
find um interesting but um i would like
to know yeah more about you so you um
converted to islam
nine years ago right and yeah how did
that come about like how did you yeah i
think by answering the question i think
it would also answer what islam is about
yes
one stone uh with me
i used to live a lifestyle of
when i was in the in london i used to be
involved with gangs so i like fighting
yeah i never went down the route of
drugs and stuff like that i i never
smoked i never drank uh that was for
health reasons why is the train kids
yeah so when i was young i used to get
into trouble here you know easter obey
my parents so my dad he used to live out
up the north near doncaster okay so he
took me there so i can calm down a bit
so i did transition from one kind of
almost
kind of another in the context i
wouldn't really well it depends what you
define as drama because i went from that
to more like clubbing right
parties
having fun all that kind of stuff so
yeah to me it was
i always acknowledged that there's a
higher power i always acknowledged and
realized that there is a creator
but to me it was like okay but why would
that creator create me without a purpose
so i was in this dilemma where i was
like okay there's a high power there i'm
not really concerned or bothered about
it but i started to ask myself a
question
sorry ally
baby come here holly holly what's all
this all right
trying to be a big dog sorry sorry about
that guys baby what's all that barking
stay in there darling
yeah dead baby
i don't know if she's better with me or
not baby stop barking what's all that
barking it's all that barking
so always the little dogs they bark the
loudest yeah right stay in there
sorry about that guys
yeah so i was i was just asking myself a
question and i couldn't i could remember
one moment i was kind of
pondering upon my socks now you might
think the wise socks sucks that's very
random yeah it was quite random and i
was looking at it and i was thinking
wow it has design yeah some form of a
design it's meant for my feet
it has a purpose right
if she has design it should have a
designer so i was thinking like you know
the main thing it was was that it has a
purpose my socks that are quite smelly
can be at times ollie yeah oh my god
guys that's the secret that ali has just
revealed to you guys
get the laundry detergent out
so the thing is here
it had a purpose so i said to myself
hold on a second man
it has a purpose
and mia socks has a purpose what's my
purpose like how could socks have a
purpose and i don't have a purpose right
so it was something where it just made
me think where i was like well what is
my purpose because i'm i'm designed and
fashioned in a way more complex than
mere socks you know so i said what is my
purpose that is where i embarked on my
journey to find out why am i here where
am i going because you know
only if he was on the train if he was
both on the train and we just woke up on
this train and this train had everything
we could ever want yeah yeah and let's
say this train is heading to korea
it's got to be to korea yeah okay i'll
be on that i'll be first on that train
so the thing is here the first question
we'll ask yourself is this okay good
everything we've got the best food
everything's on the train but at one
moment of time you're going to say to
yourself first you put me on this train
and where the hell is this train going
yeah
if you didn't know it's going to korea
right yeah so the thing is here
that we have to come to that realization
ask ourselves i didn't choose to look
like this you choose to look the way you
did right you didn't choose your name or
your siblings or your father you've been
put in this earth and you have to ask
yourself that question and it begs the
question why am i here so to me i was
just pondering and i thought to myself
there has to be a greater purpose than
this that's when i acknowledged and said
this creator that created me cannot be a
creator that gives no purpose you know
because if he has created all this he
must be magnificent you know if he has
created me my eye my fingerprint doesn't
matter fingerprint he must be
magnificent so what does he want from me
and how do i get to know him because i
want to be able to what can you give
back exactly so that's when i embarked
on that journey i looked at christianity
i was reading the bible at one point i
looked down to the old testament judaism
sikhism a bit of sikhism hinduism
and personally i had a criteria and the
criteria was if any if i'm going to
follow any religion or any text
that text should be from
god but he has to have evidence that is
from god yeah because
put my life on change your lifestyle
completely yeah because it's actually a
whole way of life that you're changing
on something that i'm not certain about
and i'm someone that has to be certain
when i do something you know so i spent
about three years and i read the quran
etc and one condition i had was if any
scripture that claims to be from god it
should have no corruptions yeah it
should not be changed by man the only
one that i found that was the quran
because the christians today they do
admit that there has been some you know
changes by men mankind
like you know that have written it to
themselves expect they claim that they
were inspired but there's also many
areas of contradictions and that to me
was that i can't believe in something
that if god has sent it for it to have
errors in it
but the quran was the only one that i
found that with and with the quran it
gave me a purpose in life in the context
where i used to go clubbing i used to
you know
be involved in relationships etc but one
thing stood out for me was that i used
to have this and i mentioned this a lot
i just have this specific jumper that i
have in my cupboard until this day
and it's it's a specific material that
makes you itchy
oh i don't really like those jumpers
yeah i really hate them yeah and some of
them are really nice i want to buy them
yeah they look nice but they make you
itch it's like oh
yeah so that jumper i can remember i
used to wear that a lot because i
believe i looked really good in it yeah
i don't know but you didn't feel good in
it you were like itching the whole time
and scratching it
why am i why am i wearing this if it
makes me feel like this that was where
things were making i was like hold on a
second
i'm actually a slave to this jumper this
this this jumper is my master right and
then i will do a lot of things for the
opposite gender
so go to the gym
earn a certain living
to have a certain lifestyle etc just so
i can please opposite gender right now
what i realized to myself at that moment
was i have a lot of masters and i'm
serving these i'm not a slave to them
like what can i do to please them
i had to break those shackles so that's
why
there was a famous uh philosopher i
always forget his name but he said man
is born
don't worry i understand
he just starts to get involved you know
he's jealous because we're talking
so i i said to myself and that's what
i'm what philosopher said he said man is
born free but in shackles everywhere
that's true so so that's where i said to
myself i have to break these shackles
and free myself i don't want to live for
others yes it's good to look after
yourself don't get twisted you know i
still go gym and train until this day
yeah but i'm doing it for myself not for
other people for other people and more
so for the one who created me because
now i've i've believed i have a
relationship yeah i broke those shackles
and that's what islam did to me and
that's what the core message of islam is
which answers your question is that it's
here to free you from the shackles of
society and peer pressure and what
others want from you to
being obedient to the one who's created
you and building that relationship with
him because he has promised us a eternal
life of paradise yeah this is the way of
life yeah no i agree with what you're
saying because we're all born into this
world where you're right we have so many
shackles we're all a slave to something
whether that's entertainment whether
that's fashion we all have these
restrictions that we put on our lives
and we're always trying to please other
people but you're right we don't
emphasize on ourselves you know on
improving ourselves on just accepting
that we should be grateful to be in this
world and you know like you said just
having a pair of socks is like yeah
that's been made you know it's you you
think more deeply about things and i
that's what i want to do i want to think
more deeply about things and i want to
get away from that lifestyle you know
it's the materials and stuff it's you
know i it's nice but it doesn't mean
anything you know it's all about how you
feel inside whether there's a higher
power you know
how you connect with that and how you
appreciate and every day you wake up
you're grateful for being born being
able to breathe being able to walk
you know these are these are things that
we take for granted and you're right
this world does have so many like
shackles like we're all trying to yeah i
mean you know i can't really talk i'm
trying to be someone that i'm not but
like we all have that precious societal
pressure to be someone else and it's
like we it's that's why i think islam is
great we can you know really embrace
our soul and who we are and actually
focus on
uh you know gratitude and appreciating
things yeah exactly definitely you know
at the end of the day you know there is
like there's we believe in two kind of
realities there's the physical reality
and there's a metaphysical reality
so like for example we know gravity
exists like the fire
yeah that's that shows us that gravity
exists yeah i say physical law
i know that
you know if i try to unless you're harry
potter try to go through you're gonna
bang your head yeah have you ever tried
that king's cross nine platform nine
three quarters try to run i usually like
to get my friends to try it first
yeah let them be foolish yeah my mom
said let your friends try first if
nothing happens then you can go yeah
so the thing is yeah it's these are
physical laws but we also as muslims
believe in a metaphysical law so we
believe god has created us with this
physical nature yes physical laws which
we know our boundaries we know when we
cross the road we just look left and
right because we might get hit by a car
but there's also a metaphysical reality
yeah now that metaphysical reality is
what is something that connects to our
soul because i look at some people when
i go to the gym and i see them training
and they have a very strict regime where
it's like for example
eating uh you know the not the yolk but
like the egg whites right for protein to
build up muscle yeah sleeping certain
amount of hours drinking protein shake
training this muscle group of muscle in
this way and i'm like the attention that
you give to your body which is alright
by the way as muslims we believe your
body has a right over you yeah and it
will testify on the day of judgment for
against you how you look after it but
the thing is here is that if that person
can give that effort to his body which
is the right and i i totally accept that
what about the soul and that's the
reason why i believe we have a pandemic
of young people with mental illness
because
we are too busy feeding the salt which
is nutrition which needs food we need
sleep and other elements to survive but
when you neglect the soul that is where
people hit an empty place and that's why
in the quran god almighty says that
indeed with my remembrance do heart find
peace and if you forget my remembrance
you will have a depressed life so it's
as if god is saying i've programmed you
in a way that you will only find
happiness if you have a connection with
me
in a nutshell islam is that it just
tells you to free yourself from mankind
and servitude to them to servitude to
god so instead of trying to prove your
like like with myself to prove myself to
others right i'm like you know what why
don't i prove myself to the one who
created me because he's more deserving
because he's the one who sustains me he
looks after me yeah so i know these
people i'm trying to impress
are they gonna come to me my grave when
i die are they gonna talk bad of me are
they even gonna give a damn about me
they might even talk bad on me so the
thing is here i want to occupy myself
and focus myself to the creator because
i believe in this life in the hereafter
and in paradise that he is the one that
will look after me so to me that was
what really like you know changed me you
know yeah you know i think i need to do
more of that you know focusing on the
soul and connecting to above because i
do always feel like i'm always trying to
please other people like i used to get
bullied when i was younger and stuff and
no you know and we all go for it you
know i'm sure you've had it as well
we'll go through it
yeah when i was younger yeah and you
know maybe even now you still get
bullied on youtube and stuff you know
we'll get that as creators but um yeah i
feel like i should i need to focus less
on that and focus more on what's inside
and focus on you know uh giving back to
you know the universe or the higher
power and uh you know removing these
restrictions because they like you said
they're about people that go to the gym
they're so regimented they eat their egg
whites they're set a time every day it's
like that's not a life to live you know
we are so blessed to be in this world
we're so blessed to to have a life you
know we're all individual like you said
we all have individual fingerprints all
individual looks
you know i think it's i need to focus
less on that and i want to focus more on
uh satisfying my soul and you know
appreciating uh the world more exactly
and i think if you do that because like
i said before these people would never
be pleased with you you know there was
there was a scholar he he was basically
he he used to have friends a group of
friends and this group of friends always
used to say to him you know
why you always he used to visit the
graveyards a lot so they used to say why
are you always at the graveyard why
don't you come and sit with us and he
said to and he said to them look
when i'm with you guys you know you all
you do is just remind me of this life
and when i leave you you're probably
back by me you talk bad of me when i go
to the graves they remind me of the
hereafter
and at least they don't talk ill of me
right and also he's showing respect to
the dead and like you said when we die
it's like it's kind of sad because all
these people are trying to please
they're not going to turn up to see us
they people forget about us and that's
kind of the sad thing so obviously what
you're saying about islam is that kind
of afterlife there as you said janna the
paradise
that is you know something to focus on
and and find a purpose in this life and
on to the next one yeah because then
when it does it gives you a greater
purpose you know this life is like they
say it's like um
a shadow like when you're walking down
the beach
when you
like
if you turn your back against your
shadow it has no choice but to follow
you right so this life is like that you
know yeah once you run after the shadow
it's like this life you're never going
to achieve it yeah when you turn your
back against it it has no choice but to
follow you right so the one that
sacrifices this life and when we
sacrifice it doesn't mean like you don't
have like people think i'm like a boring
guy like i'm a religious order you're
fine you're really funny man i'm i i
like to like there's a lot of like i'm
quite funny you know i like you you are
you're entertaining yeah you know yeah
there's i'm just because i pray i say
this him to my dad i'm like dad i'm
still seeing me you know you know you're
a human being it's like people shouldn't
judge you based on your religion or
whatever you do in your life you're a
human being and you know you are fun
you're entertaining and you know we all
have characteristics we'll have a
personality you know and people should
appreciate that more and you know
it's sad because the world is so
judgmental like you probably get it um
being muslim you probably get judgments
you know i get judgment online for
whatever my life choices and stuff so
it's like we all have this one chance in
life you know we have to give back to
the world give back to others help
others and i know that's important with
islam is to to help others you know help
your neighbors yeah oh yeah definitely i
don't i just want to maybe if there's
any questions you want to ask please
feel free to yeah but just from my point
the one thing i could also leave that
with you as well is that
what i said before is
you will truly find contentment like i i
sometimes like there's a lot of things
god has given me like a lot of blessings
i'll be honest with you this thing
youtube the thing that i do i i don't do
it for in like i don't do it for the
fame et cetera i didn't want to be able
to do it to help others you know to
spread that message
yeah and the thing is when you have that
connection with god almighty there is
nothing on this earth that can replace
that like i'm just getting the glimpse
of it i'm just feeling it and to me it's
like if god almighty took everything for
me like my car my house etc once you
know your purpose and you're not there
to please others you have this inner
completion it's it's you feel whole and
that is something that you cannot buy
and people like i said before
wasting that energy on people that's
what i learned to pleasing them it just
didn't work and i knew it's these people
they talk bad about me behind my back
right they're never gonna have that's
why when you focus towards the creator
and you're like okay he's deserving of
worship he's created me he's created
this universe there are more sans
there's more stars than there are some
particles in our universe yeah how
magnificent he must be and how merciful
he must be that he wants an eternal
paradise because if god exists and he
has created all these flavors and
pleasures like you know when you have
intimacy with your partner it's a
pleasure when you go and eat a certain
food you taste it yeah especially korean
food when you try that kimchi it's very
popular
but it's spicy guys i don't know if ali
can handle the spice hopefully
yeah
so what i'm saying is all these
pleasures god has given us when we sleep
it's sweet you know so it's not we're so
blessed you know to have these uh
experiences it's not hard for god some
people say oh when i die i'm gonna come
back if you think about it we were dead
before like before we came to life what
was we we was dead whatever yeah so we
came back
to life it's not hard for god almighty
created heavens in the earth to bring us
back to life and interest to paradise so
that's the only thing i would leave on
that i don't want to like drag it too
much but if there's anything you would
like to ask me specifically feel free to
if not
i just i just think yeah i definitely
will take on board what you said and i
want to start connecting with um
something else because you know i'm not
happy with my life you know it's i'm i'm
a very positive happy person but you
know with the abuse i get online you
know i keep changing my face and i just
can't help it i'm kind of like addicted
to doing that and addicted to trying to
make myself happy by looking in the
mirror and stuff and i know that's not
the key to happiness and that's not the
key to finding yourself so i just want
to start focusing on you know finding
the real me inside and also connecting
with um you know that higher power and
being a better person and realizing you
know this life is we have a chance in
this life to do something great you know
to give back to help others and like you
do with your youtube you spread a
message of something that you're very
passionate about and you know you're
educating people on that and you know
that's that's a very great thing you're
doing and
don't forget like allah says in the
quran until like the servant that calls
upon me i will respond to him so god
doesn't say muslim he says anyone that
calls upon me i will respond to him yeah
so i want you to know
your relationship with god almighty this
is what's very unique and beautiful
about islam is that with other religions
you have an intermediary like you need
someone to go through
with islam it tells you
worship god alone you do not go have to
go for prophet muhammad or jesus you
have a direct relationship with god all
you have to do you don't need to have a
statue in front of you or something else
all these kind of rituals it's a direct
relationship with god where you can ask
and say look god if you're there guide
me i'm looking for truth yeah i'm i'm
not happy or i'm trying to be happy i'm
trying to find my purpose guide me when
you ask god it's upon god to guide you
you know so anytime you feel down that
one connection that personal connection
yeah
i don't need to go through bts and say
bts am i connecting with you right now i
need to go yes
and the band's the k-pop band that jimin
said yeah you know at the end of the day
this is very fundamental you have a
direct relationship with god almighty
and
you use that he's there you've got
nothing to lose nothing exactly
go home
have a moment and just say god if you
are there i feel lost i would like you
to guide me guide me to whatever is the
truth whatever you deem give me inner
happiness allow me to be happy with
myself and asking for help like i have a
lot of struggles when i first came to
islam there was bad habits that i had i
couldn't but it's by prayer and asking
god and asking him because i know i
can't do it but i know you can let me do
it yeah you can help me like you said
you had such a different lifestyle back
then and you know like you said parting
and stuff and i don't go to parties and
stuff but my lifestyle now is kind of
extreme you know putting my body through
these surgeries you know
all this stuff that happens online and
stuff so it's like i want to get away
from that and just focus on you know the
soul that's the most important thing and
that connection with you know you know
and i can relate with you just to finish
on this it's not going to relate like
for example like my nose if you see it
it's got like a little bit of a hump
yeah it looks fine it looks great yeah
okay
when i was young i used to get bullied a
bit like i wouldn't because of the shape
of your nose i wouldn't say bullied what
i would say is i wasn't happy with my uh
the shape of my nose right so
i obviously you had friends who had a of
basically a little girls etc you know so
he was this little young 16 year old kid
and i didn't feel happy within myself
you didn't have confidence yeah too
precious that were putting a pressure on
me to look at certain ways yeah and i
could remember thinking okay i think i
should get my nose done yeah so i can i
know to please other people when they
look at you exactly
i came to realization i said why would i
do something that they're not going to
be happy and maybe i might not be happy
with the shape of it i'm trying to say
so i wish i could be like that ali i've
had six nose
yeah it's not too late just because
you've done it of course it's no problem
yes there's it is never too late in
islam god almighty says if your sins
were to reach the heavens and the earth
i will forgive every single one of them
as long as you don't associate partners
with me which is what in islam which is
fundamental that god asks you to worship
him alone so you don't go to anyone else
yeah not creation not statute so i can't
go to jimin i can't go to bts yes no
more praying
you can admire them of course this could
be someone that you look up to right but
the connection don't forget they if you
think about it
what like if i saw muhammad ali today
i'll be a bit gassed and excited yeah
but what's my like suppose what is he
paying for my bills no he's a human
being though it's like just like you
exactly yeah i can be excited because it
really is yeah now imagine if i'm
excited to see muhammad ali or you see
information imagine me saying jimin i
think i would be more than excited
okay yeah what we need is we need to
redirect that love and energy yeah to
the right so yeah that one that deserves
it yeah you have not there's no problem
admiring
figures and etc there's no problem i'm
not saying that but for example to go to
the level of
as if you're worshiping them is where
islam says look who's more deserving of
worship jimin are the one that created
him so if you want if you admire in him
yeah you should admire the creator more
that created him yeah you think about if
you admire him i like his looks whatever
it may be and you want to be like him
what about the creator that created them
exactly
much more because he made german exactly
yeah exactly yeah and on a nice last one
yeah because the camera man he's a bit
ill and
so the thing is here
if i was to come here and say to you i
will give you one million pounds oh you
know what money means maybe nothing
i'm going to bring jimin you're going to
spend every weekend with jimmy if you
could ground that wish
okay
yeah what is if i was to do that because
i know that's your dream if i had to do
that
and i said i don't want nothing from you
what would you do like is there anything
that you would do like for example let's
suppose i just went about my life yep
would you consider calling me checking
up on me absolutely yeah would you think
like you know what let me check up on
ali every now and then you'd be my new
best friend if you brought me jimin
anyone that brought me to memphis
but you know i'm a very appreciative
person so if anyone does something for
me i believe in the power of the
universe if you give something good you
it's always good to give it back you
know and that's like you said doing
something that's going to make someone
smile doing something that's going to
make someone happy and yeah that's not
the universe but it's good to do it yeah
so it's just shifting the focus so what
i was saying is you would appreciate
what i've done right of course what
we've seen is yeah god has given us this
life
if he's given us all of this the least
we can do is acknowledge him and build
that connection with him that's analogy
that's the thing that i was trying to
give you yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean
that's it from me is there anything else
you would like no i don't know i find
that very interesting and like i said
when i met you last time i wanted to
learn more about it because i didn't a
purpose in my life you know i do feel a
bit lost i go a bit crazy with the
surgeries and my k-pop obsession so like
i want to
actually you know be more real and you
know you should you should you know what
once you find that right
wear this
[Laughter]
yeah so i think once you find that that
is priceless man yes you understand your
focus why you're here where you're going
building inner confidence and happiness
i mean look how happy you are ali like
you are so grateful with your life
you're so you're always i met you last
time but you're so happy you're youtube
you're always happy and it's because you
have this connection with the higher
power and you're you know i i need to
find something like that yeah like i
said before prayer is powerful
olly pray man you've got nothing to lose
bro yeah no of course nothing just
simple just god i want to find in
happiness help me and jim help
yeah
inner happiness
yeah so go to the one that's all hearing
right all knowing and ask him ask him
yeah if you want to meet jimin ask him
say god i want to see jimin i actually
should do that yeah actually when you
see jimmy have you ever seen him
okay you know what maybe one day when
you see him you might be like you know
what
maybe it wasn't all that maybe maybe
maybe i'm seeing me
actually okay i mean it was good it was
okay
no it's never going to be like that i
promise you yeah
so in a nutshell i'll just say look i'm
here if you have any questions thank you
i'm at your service so thank you
you know what
um i heard this about islam or i would
like some clarification yeah i
appreciate that you know
i love it and doing this video with me
you will get some of my haters coming to
you by the way uh they would want to
come and oh he said this he said that
yeah
i never listened to hate you know i'm
just i'm just yeah yeah because they see
this relationship right they do not like
that a non-muslim of course a muslim can
come to a table yeah have tea
you know we've got nice dogs
but you know it's a it's about we're all
human beings at the end of the day we
all have to love and embrace one another
and you know appreciate other cultures
other religions and you know i'm all
about that you're all about that and
it's about understanding other people
and you know accepting people for who
they are people might be different
religions but you know we love them
equally and you know of course of course
yeah exactly exactly we're all on like
you said we're all in this world for a
purpose and we have a purpose to you
know serve the one who created them
right and also yeah uh find our soul and
um give back to society give back to
people and also not feel that pressure
from society like you have to look a
certain way you have to dress a certain
way like that's a big pressure for you
know all young people these days they're
all concerned about their looks and you
know
yeah
pleasure it was a real pleasure i know
it's a bit cold today even though it
looks like you know what i'm saying this
is not the end we're gonna be
gonna go to korean dining coming soon
and shout out to ollie and we'll see
more videos as well
fix your affair with god and god will
fix your face with the people yeah and
i'll find you yeah i'll find out that
inner happiness yeah
um now i just want to say thank you ali
for this i really appreciate it
no i know but it's a very nice location
you know since since we met uh the
christmas in career day i was like
you're such a lovely guy and you're so
interesting and you're so well educated
and i really respect that and uh that
was that was fascinating so i need i
need to yeah i need to focus on what you
said is if you have time i would drop
some books for you like they're just
different books that will be written by
a few of my friends yeah just just like
fought pondering you know yeah sure if
you have anything like that yeah bring
them along when we go to the korean
restaurant yeah exactly yeah we can we
can talk about that but i'm definitely
looking forward to that definitely guys
it's a pleasure i was invited by ollie
we came and met some of his friends i
met some five dogs here as well you know
so yeah it was it was really nice they
liked you as well they really liked here
yeah yeah i can see that little one you
know keep looking at me
so guys i hope you enjoyed it in
charlotte if you would like a part 2
definitely do it but definitely we're
going to be having him on dining to
jannah korean restaurant it's going to
be hot it's going to be spicy very very
spicy guys
yeah who do you think is going to be
able to handle the spice more ali or
ollie
i'm not the best with spice i can i'm
used to korean food but i can't handle
super spicy but we should maybe
challenge ourselves like the spiciest
dish
and if i die please
same guys for me